our journey starts in a tower where a
battle took place long ago atop the
tower our fallen Knights of drangleic
covered in ash and surrounding a brittle
husk for long ago scores of men were
dispatched to this land to tap the
replete stores of iron however they soon
lost their nerve when faced with the
child of dark these men conquered the
dark creature that inhabited this tower
and ash is all that remains of it we
find six wedges of iron embedded in this
creatures chest the tools used to defeat
it these are smelter wedges forged to
destroy the ashen Idol one can assume
that this night at the base of the idol
carried out that vast task
killing the idol in his final moments we
see what the ashen Idol is capable of in
the next tower a tower that feels very
much alive where the previous one felt
dead where before we saw an ashen husk
now we see a living creature the child
of dark guarding the old iron king's
throne erecting great pillars of black
flame in an attempt to keep us away we
have seen three children of dark thus
far women who are fragments of Manas an
ancient evil from Dark Souls 1 there is
nashandra the queen of vendrick Elana
the queen of the sunken King and Natalya
the woman who would be the queen of the
iron King had she not arrived after his
death when Natalia came to this land of
iron the King she sought was no longer
there dispirited she forsook her own
soul and clung to the heirlooms of the
old king the ashen Idol is of great
consequence to Natalya a child of dark
who renounced her flesh and entrusted
her soul to these ashen vessels as we
journey through the tower we hear her
whispering we have just defeated the old
iron king the man who would have been
her husband all players will have his
soul at this point and I believe that
this is why her whispering seems to
mistake us for her King
it's also possible that she sees us as
the next king a king who has come to
take the crowns from previous rulers
there are 12 action idols hidden within
this tower vessels that house the
Queen's soul they haunt the tower and
only when we've destroyed all 12 will
the whispering stop this child of dark
bearing inconceivable strength found
herself in a kingless land devoid of
souls once you get all the fragments her
completed soul tells us that once she
came to this kingless land and she
enveloped the entire tower in a swirling
dancing black fog once she realized her
king wasn't there in the act of dancing
the bride of ash was transfigured as
smoke enticing people to her residence
and so her seat of power came to be
known as the broom tower broom is a word
that means mist or fog the lonely queen
of black mist danced to entice knights
into her realm so that she could either
be entertained by their torment or
consume their souls and so scores of men
lost their nerve when faced with a
childhood dark with all but the most
steadfast of them becoming servants of
the black fog it's worth noting I think
that there is a trend here in both sets
of DLC we have received so far
so both the sunken city and the iron
towers have had the Knights of drangleic
assaulting them once the kings of paths
and once the Queens have taken over so
think about it both sets of drangleic
Knights have different reasons for
attacking the Drake blood Knights who we
think are drangleic Knights based on
your gring resembling the crest of
drangleic they assaulted silver to slay
the dragon and the Knights of drangleic
here at the iron tower are supposedly
attacking in order to claim the large
quantities of iron hidden within but is
it possible that they're actually trying
to get back the Crown's of the previous
Kings and is it possible that the Queens
who arrived after the Kings are dead is
it possible that they are defending
these crowns for whoever has all the
crowns can truly ascend the throne of
want my theory is that vendrick is
sending knights of drangleic to retrieve
the crowns but he's failing because
every fallen Kingdom is now protected by
the dark Queens so vendrick once he
realizes that nashandra is a queen of
his own he locks himself and his own
crown away to buy time while we seek to
reunite the crowns before the Queens do
I believe it's most likely that the
wandering Knights of drangleic who
venture here turned into the goofy
hollowed barrel workers where the ashen
soldiers seemed to be the remaining
soldiers of the old iron King's Kingdom
based on the armor they're wearing in
speaking of armor the third enemy we
find is a possessed suit of armor once
these suits of armor were decorations
until the black fog ruling the tower
seize control of them so we've talked
about this tower in its current state it
was once the foundations of a great
Kingdom a kingdom that was powerful
because of its ability to forge and
utilize great stores of iron the queen
who arrived at this kingdom came too
late and she found her King gone and she
found the kingdom abandoned so who was
this King and where has he gone at the
bottom of the staircase below the throne
of the old iron king we see a suit of
armor this is the armor of sir alonne a
knight who had a huge role in creating
this Kingdom and after we talk about him
you'll understand how this Kingdom came
to be sir alonne came to this land from
the east chose to serve a little known
and unestablished lord and helped him to
become the old iron king the iron king
was not born into his title you can tell
that from that description a semi
powerful Lord he rested this dilapidated
region from the kingdom of ven this act
required all the resources the enfeebled
Lord could muster after claiming this
kingdom the iron king was weak his
resources all but spent he was a king
but king of a feeble Kingdom however
just at the right moment he found
something awesome he found this
scorching iron scepter this scepter
allowed him to mold iron freely as if he
held sway over the forces of life and
creation with the discovery of this iron
producing miracle he was reborn as a
powerful leader the Kings
experimentation with iron shows
throughout the entire kingdom and just a
spoiler it leads to his demise
anyway the iron clad set tells us of the
iron clad soldiers minions created by
the old iron king a set of armor with
life granted by the enchantment of souls
the tower key tells us that the tower
was renowned for producing a seemingly
endless supply of iron the King used it
to create iron soldiers and denying
castle and we all know how creating that
iron castle turned out anyway legend has
it he even tried his hand at forging a
dragon out of iron I really wish there
was more information given on this
dragon I mean seriously
a dragon is it just me or are we seeing
another example of history repeating
itself every great Kingdom seems to have
a great dragon vendrick created the
ancient dragon that's the first one
silver worshiped the sleeping dragon and
the iron Kingdom planned to craft their
own dragon so with these Kings following
an ancient mural they found on the wall
or is fate guiding their actions
anyway the iron King went on to do great
and terrible things his exploits even
extended to the Huntsman's cops the iron
king commanded the capture of all undead
but those charged with tasks were
overcome by the curse the executioner's
chariot was created only to torment
undead and he crushes undead underfoot
endlessly in the undead purgatory and
this is a place for undead to supposedly
experience punishment just for their
existence around this time the old lion
King's friend Sir Rowland left the
service of the King was it because of
the atrocities the king was committing
for at the very peak of his rule sir
alonne set out again in search of lands
yet unknown moving on from sir alonne in
our journey through the Kings abandoned
tower we find that Minotaur
he dominates the place the minitor helm
was commissioned by the old iron king
wearing it gives the sensation of being
smothered in iron the Minotaur was the
idol of Eagle has proven by the naming
of a bonfire in the old iron keep it's
called idols Idol in reference to the
giant Minotaur presiding over the place
I'd rule was a Pyromancer and he was a
loyal follower of the old iron king and
though I say he but idols gender is not
known it was idols habit to create
powerful pyromancies such as the dance
of fire and fire snake with the latter
pyromancy telling us that Idol sought to
grant fire a will of its own Idol the
Pyromancer succeeded in this he created
the smelter demon which we can all thank
him for the smelter demon is a mass of
iron that has been given a soul was this
metal goliath there from the beginning
or was it a product of the Kings conceit
I mentioned that idols gender was
unknown because it's possible that Idol
may have been a woman we know that he's
guilty of giving fire a will of its own
does this ring a bell this is a sin
attributed to the lost sinner a woman
who willingly imprisoned herself within
the bastille for the great sin of trying
to relight the first flame whether Idol
is the lost sinner or not Idol committed
a great sin he created the smelter demon
a massive enchanted iron powered by fire
a being that came to life and killed the
old iron king the earth spouted fire and
a beast arose from the flames the
short-sighted king was incinerated by
the creature in one swing and his castle
devoured in a sea of flames the human
ego
how many ugly iron castles has it
erected and they don't even see the
folly of their ways it reminds me of
someone who lived long ago a
vainglorious liar who ended up hurling
himself into the flames
now he's Icarus earth if I'm not
mistaken the king sunk below his
scorching iron met the one whose name
must never be repeated and became the
vessel that
icarus earth a giant winged demon this
description and the soul of the old iron
king tells us that the king was
possessed by the things that lurk below
what are these things that cannot be
named it could be two things since the
old iron king also has the soul of Gwyn
it could be Gwen's soul found deep below
the earth that infused with the King to
create Icarus earth the giant winged
demon it could also be Manus found deep
below in the abyss
manases name is deliberately avoided by
king vendrick and all item descriptions
after all and perhaps Manas corrupted
him in some way regardless this is the
Kings fate and it's the abrupt end to
his very prosperous Kingdom now in the
present day the Dark Queen has come to
lay claim to their kingdom just like all
the dark Queens before her and she comes
to be the bride of the iron King however
when she arrives she finds the King has
gone so she haunts the tower instead
there was one before us who came to
explore this tower of black mist as it
came to be known after the Queen came
his name the man who came here was rain
and he is the brother of well start who
is the hand of the king Raymondville
start were known as the left and right
arms of the King until their wills
clashed and RAM was deemed a traitor the
rebel reign after his defeat by false
start came to broom tower in search of
greater strength when he found it it
came not from a regal father as before
but from a newfound mother who gave him
troopers Ram was a distinguished Knight
who became infatuated with the bride of
ash and he settled in this land of fog
the Exile swordsman ram had the ability
to expunge the black fog to remove it
from this land but he chose to live
alongside it in the company of the child
of dark that haunts his sword we defeat
rain in combat and we lay claim to the
second crown the crown of the old iron
king I've got a challenge for you I've
chosen five things that you might have
missed in the iron crown DLC and I want
to see if you can get all five I like
doing things you
episodes alongside story mode because it
just feels really complete for an area
there's also an entire playlist of this
stuff if that's your thing I hope you
enjoyed this video if you haven't
already consider subscribing feel free
to rate the video blah blah blah and
I'll catch you guys in the next one bye